hello in this video we'll talk about
mycoplasma
microplasma are so far known smallest
bacterial species on planet earth they
have very simple structure
genetic material dna soluble rna and
proteins are encapsulated in a
trilaminar membrane and if we zoom into
the membrane we can understand this
membrane is very densely packed with
cholesterol
they can survive without the oxygen and
they can come in different shapes for
example m genitalium is a fluctuate
bacteria whereas
pneumonia is more elongated in their
shape so they can change their shape and
size so this is basically a nature of
highly piomorphic organisms
microplasma lacks cell wall that is why
they don't really take up gram staining
and it's very hard for the technicians
to detect them
they can be parasitic or saprophytic
many species of microplasma are found in
sewage and soils
not all of them are pathogenic some of
them are such as micro microplasma
pneumoniae
so mnemoni or any kind of microplasma
species forms a characteristic fried
egg-like structure on agar plate and
this is really characteristic of
microplasma
nickname of mycoplasma is
pluto-pneumonia-like
organism because they are involved in
pneumonia
so mnemoni
is responsible for walking pneumonia
which is very common in school kids it's
basically a mild atypical form of
pneumonia
other than that m genitalium
is believed to be involved with pelvic
inflammatory disease and bacterial
vaginosis
so mg genitalium can grow on the vagina
and it can lead to vaginal discharge if
the growth is too much and often it
smells like fish
microplasma hominis lives in the urinary
tract and genitals
of
women and it's very common
and very it is rare in males
so they're generally okay they don't
cause
great harm
but if the woman has good health it's
not a problem but sometimes
if the woman has
weakened immune response then it might
lead to infections
microplasma harmonies can
be
transferred from mother's body to the
baby so it can cause fever in the
newborns
also
there are other species like uroplasma
and
urea plasma
those can actually
infect the female reproductive tract and
they are generally found in cervix and
vagina
and also they are present in smaller
number in male in their urethra
so normally they don't cause any problem
but sometimes they can spread to the
partner during sex
and also they can be transmitted from
mother's body to the uh to the baby in
the womb or during the childbirth and it
can cause harm to the newborn baby
so obviously
these microplasma species can affect you
during sex so using a condom or
contraceptive can help you
not getting this particular bacteria
microplasma is actually a nightmare in
cell culture labs
because
generally worldwide there are reports
that all cell culture media are highly
contaminated with microplasma and in
fact these days scientists prefer to do
always microplasma testing in a routine
basis
so the question is that whether
microplasma can be killed by antibiotics
it turns out beta lag lactose
antibiotics such as penicillin can not
harm these bacteria because they don't
have a cell wall and beta-lactam
antibiotics work on the cell wall
so other antibiotics like tetracycline
which works by preventing the
translation to occur or prevents new
protein synthesis can be effective
against mycoplasma so doxycycline can be
a good treatment option for mycoplasma
infection not any beta-lactam
antibiotics such as penicillin
so i hope this video was informative let
us quickly summarize microplasma lac
cell wall they don't take up drum stain
they can be parasitic and saprophytic
there are several species which are
pathogenic to human we discussed few of
them
nickname of microplasma is also pplo
because they cause plural pneumonia
betel active antibiotics are ineffective
against microplasma so tetracyclines or
doxycyclines can be used to treat
microplasma infection microplasma is a
nightmare in cell culture lab because
they can grow nicely on cell culture and
contaminate the cell culture media
so i hope this video was useful if you
like this video don't forget to support
my channel on patreon if you're a indian
viewer you can support using the bim upi
app don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can find my courses in
academy which is india's biggest
learning platform you can also connect
to me via social media all my social
media handles are provided in the
description
so don't forget to follow my facebook
page as well thanks for listening let me
know in the comments how you like my
video thank you